- [Woman] Our goal is to
just pay off our debt.
- Yes.
- So we just surrendered and
said we've gotta insurance
and just kill it.
And it failed. And we lost everything.
- That happens.
- [Woman] I'm in conflict
'cause I'm tired.
We got three kids. I don't sleep.
- Yep.
- I grind.
- And I'm tired.
- Yep. And so I understand all that.
That all makes sense.
So what's the question?
- How do you know
without risking it again,
how do you know just
to take the leap again?
I don't want to lose no more.
- You're looking at the past.
- But, I struggle so hard with my anxiety,
my, I can't handle it, so.
- It's either coming, it's
coming from one or two places.
You're allowing somebody else to judge you
or you're judging yourself.
- Myself.
- I'm telling you the number
one thing that fascinates me
about people is they take the past
and give it so much credit.
And they underestimate the
current and the future.
You're looking dead in the
face of getting results.
Yet the fear of the
replication of something
that happened before is
stopping you from going.
So I think this is about making a decision
and not dwelling,
or pondering on what if because
what if's cripple people.
You will regret not going for it
way more than if you fail a second time.
Everybody here right now can sit here
and say what if about something.
I should've stuck with ball.
I should've invested
in Facebook. You know?
Like, "What if's scare the out of me!"
So taking action especially
if it doesn't cost you money
and it's just time, is
always a better answer
than pondering or thinking
or trying to decide
if this is going to work, you don't know.
The learning of the failure is as equal
to the victory of it.
I'd rather lose again.
Like what? Like what, you
could lose your house.
People are scared of
things that aren't real.
things that are not real.
It's life. Nobody knows what
is going to happen tomorrow.
- So how do you, and I'm sorry,
- It's all right, go ahead.
- How do you deal with the unknown?
- By recognizing I have no choice.
You guys got love for each
other and those three kids,
you could be homeless and happy.
You could,
(audience clapping)
you could, you could.
I mean, you know, might not be ideal.
It might be better, but like,
I'm just trying to ask
people what they're scared of
and what they're scared
of, if they go all the way
to the core, is other people's opinions.
By not worrying about
what other people think,
it allows you to do things by
doing things you either win
or you learn from your
loss and it creates speed.
It's the absolute mental
difference between the people
that are executing and winning,
versus the people that aren't.
It's the fear of others.
I don't want to lose,
but I'm definitely more
disappointed than your opinion
in your blog post about my loss.
I'm just looking at you
two, like they're in love.
That's good. So guess what?
You're in a great place.
What do you need? You
need Netflix? Netflix!
What do you need? You don't need anything.
I'm confused by people
creating these fake frameworks.
And so, I navigate happy
because I'm just grateful
for what I have.
And other people have more,
other people have less,
when I had a whole lot less,
I was happy with the I had.
And I just every day recognize
that if I'm in my own head
and realize that everybody's
got their own stuff too
then I don't spend time
complaining and dwelling.
I spend time on doing.
You wouldn't be scared if you realize
the worst case scenario is it'd be worse.
There'd be three of you, right?
I'm telling you right now,
those kids are not going to lose
if you guys are losing, it's
gonna make them stronger.
They all have different personalities.
But if you're instilling the right values
and showing them love,
they're going to win.
I'd much rather have loving parents
that were homeless and
instilled that in me
than successful parents that
were doing the wrong thing.
I'm gonna have a better
life. That's been proven.
People are scared of
other people's judgment.
People are scared of other
people's judgment, right?
What are people gonna
think if we lose our home?
Or we lose again?
You're pondering, you lack the confidence
because you're worried
about what people say.
I like losing.
That's why this is all so easy.
I don't give a if you said I lost.
Ah man, I'm telling you, Rocky 6.
I think that's the one
where he went back to the,
when he lost everything?
It wasn't a good movie.
And that's my favorite one
because he went back to zero.
And it's not that scary.
Who you scared of?
It's insecurity. Insecurity's poison.
Massive poison.
Stop looking backwards.
It's just, it will slow you
down to where you're going.
(light music)